here we go again I'm back to talk about
a core set of concepts and marketing
segmentation and positioning
segmentation is the process of finding
and grouping customers based on their
needs or characteristics for instance
there may be customers who care about
prestige and others who care more about
practicality these would belong to two
different segments because their tastes
are different a lot of times when people
think of segments they characterize the
difference between people as being about
their age or socioeconomic status this
is particularly common in the media
industry which refers to quote appeals
to a certain demographic the problem
with this form of segmentation is the
demographic characteristics typically
don't do a good job of helping us
predict what people will like sure there
are products like diapers and in those
cases knowing your baby is a pretty damn
good predictor of whether you'll be
consuming them but for most other
products knowing your age or where you
were born is hardly predictive so
ideally you should segment based on
customer preferences and attitudes the
tricky part is that these are harder to
observe than age or gender but these are
the key predictors of behavior
positioning is what you do to explain to
your target customer that your product
meets their needs best this can be done
by advertising pricing branding and even
based on the features you put in your
product it's where the rubber meets the
road where your customer sees that your
product meets their needs so well that
they're willing to part with their
hard-earned money to get you positioning
is critical the same product can be
positioned in two different ways and as
a result can either appeal or fail to
appeal to a mass-market
the traffic and navigation mobile app
ways for example started out with a
business model much different than what
they are known for today originally
their plan was to create inexpensive
maps by crowdsourcing information from
drivers at the time maps were expensive
to produce and to purchase and Waze was
going to provide a cheaper up-to-date
and easy to update alternative to
existing competitors the positioning was
around inexpensive navigation as it was
building its product Google launched
Google Maps which gave away its maps for
free Waze could no longer hope to charge
for map creation Google's move could
have spelled the end freeways its
founders and its employees instead the
company repositioned from navigation to
commuting what's the difference well
navigation is when we go to places we
don't know commuting is when we go to
places that we do know we don't need a
map to help us find our destination we
need a map product to help us get there
quickly
no other product Alfred this benefit as
well as ways did in the marketplace the
rest is history Waze gained tens of
millions of users and was sold to Google
for over a billion dollars segmentation
is the basis of product success because
it's at the heart of understanding
consumer needs without meaning a
consumer need a product fails plain and
simple but doing a thorough analysis
isn't enough you also need your targeted
segment to perceive you as the solution
to their problem this is where
positioning comes into play in our
course we discussed each of these
concepts in depth